I think in the year maybe 2004-2005 okay
football season as a team as a you speed
you told me Bob here yeah I'm going to
get McDonough's after this who's the
better receiver soon right here think
about it who's the better receiver yeah
well I think TOS Lunda top three
receivers in the history of the sport
that's a lie let me tell you why tell me
why he's not the better receiver he had
the better cards dealt to him and took
advantage of those opportunities
[Laughter]
no I'm gonna make you stop right there
because I'm gonna play with Steve yellow
three years Oh Stevie on three years
that's it I don't care who you played
outside of that you have a person you
had Carson please a Heisman Trophy wait
for the 49 that has nothing to do
there's no the 49 it's not good these
are awesome organizations right I came
in I was Bo according to everybody else
and I made the most of the car that I
was right so really what ideas that
don't tell how you finish talking I
played with the Buffalo Bills I'm
nothing and got off that's I'm not
finished not played with Cincinnati
babies with yous ain't got off was there
one part of the game anything part of
the game that you stole from each other
where you were like damn I couldn't I
couldn't do anything he did honestly his
DNA is makeup his skill set is
completely I mean night and day yeah
completely the stuff he would do the
stiff arm in people never worked
I don't go to obviously because I was
more of a finesse player this is my
favorite thing to watch tio do yeah him
and Brandon Marshall dudes playing bump
and run let's say I'm tired fourth
quarter they had this in tugging pool
where they invite the contact I waiting
for you to get a hold and pull by how in
the yeah
I know I tried you to practice one time
I'm right there in the same spot and
that was my strength bump and run man
the man was my strength and I remember
trying their stuff I would try stuff
that other people were able to do yeah I
couldn't get away with it
so yeah you were trying to so that's the
same you know things that I use to my
advantage was obviously office opposite
of him but when I actually got what she
had like when I was in actually Dallas
yeah I played with Terry Glenn I've
never seen feet so fast so quick in my
life right then I got with Cincinnati
and I saw Chad I'm like oh my god I've
never seen quicker feet the two people
that I've seen with quick feet are teryn
and Chad Johnson yeah and everybody know
obviously with with Jerry he's done some
amazing stuff but in terms of
elusiveness feet quickness this is how
this is that's what he used to it his
neighbors family you know getting off
the line of scrimmage right me I tried
to incorporate some of that it worked
during certain times and specific points
during the course of the game but that's
his bread and butter like to get a
release or get loose that's what he goes
to like for me I'll use my physical
strength but also again I added a little
bit of that quickness with my feet at
times so that's what made me more the
dynamic receiver than he was so you're
on the Bengals what was the day when he
joined the Bengals I hate I hate lobby
for that big time with Marvin but Marvin
I said I asked Marvin you know a lot man
we really need to bring tea in I think
it would help us offensively
tremendously who was your receiver coach
god bless his soul out here Mike
shepherd I except at a time dealing with
you two in meetings must have been
amazing I would have loved them it is
easy to know when I'm working and we
unlock the air and the air I know you
both are it was it I mean again people
may think that we're uncomfortable based
on the antics and how we you know go
about but when it came to football like
literally that's what nobody gets to see
in the in the workplace when it's time
to work I remember he trying to get me
to slow down on Friday remember yeah man
righties Benham out there riot ease are
you know it goes the chilis time the
tapered I know you where else oh yeah
right man listen dude tt was later boy
I'm taking scout team yeah this is way
to my tenth ninth year I'm just out
there moving
you have the perception I remember just
I'm just growing up think about the
hurricane to the 90s yeah and that's
what I grew up watching so as a kid
growing up it was the game of football
was about having fun when you're
knitting it Phil and you misbehavior
they do something you don't like or you
don't you don't follow their rules
what's the first thing they take from
you money your money because that's what
they think you value the most but for me
the money was gonna come money cargo
it's gonna come regardless yeah which is
why I never stopped doing what I was
doing because the money was great it was
awesome
but when I didn't have any money this is
the way I played the game of football
which is why I never stopped even with
the go step further you talk about the
Hall of Fame and everybody realizes when
you're in the Hall of Fame obviously
their financial opportunities well
outside of that and so I was well or
well well aware of that and I had some
Hall of Famers even told me there's a
man you're gonna mess up these
opportunities you know for me I'm just
like Chad you know money comes and goes
and if I if I had to you know if I'm put
in a situation where I gotta choose
money over my family and friends i'ma
choose my family and friends all day and
it was just it was sad to see how the
media again they didn't they didn't
allow themselves an opportunity to know
who or who we are as people and they
went into that the perception of who
they thought we were and again we just
went out there with you it makes it more
into game no it makes it more
interesting they have their villains
they have someone to talk about there
has to be there has to be a bad costume
you know
but it had to but it's unfair like you
said because again it's it's you how can
you justify Tom Brady doing or saying
some of the same things that I've done
right right right and he's heard of the
standards never seen him curse out
coaches I've seen in berate his own
teammate
but he's looked at an upon as a leader a
champion you know so what if I if I had
to do it again
honestly the restart and had to doing
and added to it the exact same way the
wind changed